welcome back everybody our next guest
has blown my mind once already on our
show he's been described by the New York
Times as having the effervescent wit of
a good dinner party host and the cunning
of a master Joel Thief which is really
good description his hit off Broadway
show is called aie wind's Inner Circle
let's say hi to aie wind again
[Applause]
everybody
what's going on keeping busy I am very
excited you're here you know I love
magic I'm very excited how's your show
going it's going great I mean we started
a show we thought we're going to do a
couple of months and leave and pack and
we extend it six times we've done 370
shows to date that's cuz you're so
awesome it's cuz you're so good so what
are you showing us today we're going to
try something uh something to warm up
and then the main course all right so
let's like it all right so L's I'll ask
everybody here to think of a two-digit
number of the last uh passcode of your
phone let's say everybody think of it
and if you already have a number raise
your hand quick quick quick raise your
hand raise your hand all right how about
you with that beautiful jewelry it's a
wash I think uh you have a two in mind
of your last don't say it think it okay
you did that great all right I before
the show started I wrote the number on
this board no you did yeah yeah yeah
you'll see it's crazy okay if you you
don't know him right do not okay okay
ready for the first time say the number
out loud two one also known as
21 almost had the same number that is
crazy did you really think it should I
tell you the first two baby okay okay
you ready yeah you want to see it first
I just want everybody to see it there's
no way you have a two and a
one
well
exactly
[Applause]
right correct right okay okay it's
better it's better than that so when I
wrote this I used two types of markers
one is permanent and why is dry erase so
for example if you did this it will
erase right if you did here you want to
try try let say 95 try this yeah or
every one of them will erase but one
number is permanent you said 21 right
yes try to no way try to eras
21 yeah this one was mine 22 okay no no
there are many ways to write 21 I wrote
21 really big look I I'll show you what
I mean if I race everything but
everything no there's this is
21 thank you you've never met never met
him before but this is this is this is
the appetizer let's let's let's let's do
something let's do something crazy shall
we that was crazy thank you all right
let's do something crazy crazier so this
is 100 numbers we we're taking up and up
a thousand pieces of a jig puzzle now
here's the deal every person here would
say oh baby they're all the same you're
here to verify that they're different
can you they are different so grab like
mix them up a bit if you want those are
different and then pick about five or so
like like this much not too many go
ahead like about five six pieces yeah
put them here put them right in the
center here and turn them all face uh
facing up oh up okay so we can see them
and here the eyes of the also we we'll
zoom on it but you'll see even these
that are very close they're different
even that's different even the shape
every one of them can you divide them
into two groups three and three anywh
you want any three and three okay which
three either either three doesn't matter
these can I take this sure all right so
every choice you make is your own I'm
not trying to influence your choice from
these three look one two and three can
you pick any two any two of them it's up
to you any two and put them right yeah
put him in the back that's perfect I'm
so nervous okay okay is it is it fair is
it fair from a thousand you choke you
chose six then three you said get rid of
the other three then I asked you to
remove two yeah we're down to one I knew
you're going to choose this one why I'll
explain I have the exact same puzzle at
home all night I there was a lot of I
put all the pieces together yeah and I I
didn't have time to finish it I was
missing one piece no yeah uh it's right
here you are bsing me right
now it's an image and it's missing one
piece how in the world would you know
for me randomly grabbing this is not a
part of the show I'm not a part of this
you are totally can I want to remove it
it's up to you can I look at it let's do
it together ready okay just take it off
there's one image here okay
okay
no oh my
gosh that's my dog
I just got
it this is my dog
Henry oh this is my Henry it's a gift
for you oh my gosh you I need to know
how you did that you are this is why it
keeps getting extended I'm so hot right
now oh my God I'm burning up okay give
it up for aie win
everybody that is incredible
be sure to check out A's Inner Circle at
New York's Justin Theater now the
January 14th we'll be right
[Music]
[Applause]
back thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home